I
COMMUNITY.
>> ED, THANK YOU.
>>> THIS MORNING WE CAN SHOW YOU
WHAT LIFE IS LIKE FOR SOME OF
THE 19,000 MIGRANT CHILDREN IN
AMERICAN CUSTODY.
FOR THE FIRST TIME, JOURNALISTS
WERE ALLOWED INSIDE A CROWDED
BORDER FACILITY CENTER THAT WAS
SET UP TO HANDLE THE OVERFLOW OF
CHILDREN.
OFFICIALS SAID YESTERDAY ABOUT
5,200 UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN
WERE BEING HELD IN THOSE
SHORT-TERM FACILITIES.
MIREYA VILLARREAL TOURED ONE OF
THEM, A FACILITY IN DONNA,
TEXAS.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING, TONY.
THIS BORDER PATROL FACILITY
RIGHT HERE FOR UNACCOMPANIED
MINORS AND FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN IS WAY OVER CAPACITY.
BY LAW THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
BE HELD FOR MORE THAN THREE
DAYS, BUT WE KNOW ON AVERAGE
HERE IN DONNA, THEY ARE BEING
HELD FOR FIVE DAYS.
AND IN SOME CASES, UP TO TWO
WEEKS.
EVERY ROOM IS FULL.
EVERY AGENT IS BUSY, AND THIS
FACILITY STRETCHED TO THE MAX.
>> THE CAPACITY FOR THIS
LOCATION FOR COVID PURPOSES IS
250.
WE'RE HOLDING OVER 4,100
SUBJECTS IN THIS LOCATION ALONE.
>> Reporter: 3,400 OF THOSE
SO-CALLED SUBJECTS ARE
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN.
EVERYONE STARTS IN THE INTAKE
ROOM WITH MEDICAL SCREENINGS.
CHILDREN 14 AND OVER WILL HAVE
FINGERPRINTS AND PHOTOS TAKEN.
NEXT THEY'LL GET IMMIGRATION
DOCUMENTS AND A COURT DATE.
BUT FOR MOST, THAT'S WHEN THE
PROCESS STALLS.
>> WHILE BORDER PATROL IS
ALREADY DONE WITH THE ENTIRE
PROCESSING OF THESE INDIVIDUALS,
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO TURN THEM OVER
TO HHS' CUSTODY.
HHS DOES NOT HAVE THE ADEQUATE
BEDS TO BE ABLE TO TAKE ON ALL
OF THESE KIDS.
>> Reporter: SO THEY WAIT IN
THESE OVERCROWDED PODS.
THE WALLS ARE MADE OF PLASTIC,
AND THE FLOORS COVERED IN A SEA
OF FOIL BLANKETS.
>> THIS IS THE PLAYPEN.
>> Reporter: 27 OF THE YOUNGEST
UNACCOMPANIED MIGRANTS SLEEP,
EAT, AND PLAY IN A SEPARATE ROOM
CORRALLED BY A PLASTIC BABY
GATE.
>> THAT'S THE PERMANENT HOME FOR
THESE KIDS UNTIL WE'RE ABLE TO
PUT THEM AND TURN THEM OVER TO
HHS CUSTODY.
>> Reporter: HOW DOES THAT FEEL
TO YOU?
>> I'M A FATHER.
I MEAN, I DON'T WANT TO SEE
THAT.
AS A BORDER PATROL AGENT, I
DIDN'T SIGN UP FOR THIS.
THIS IS NOT THE RIGHT PLACE FOR
THESE KIDS.
>> Reporter: AND YET THE FLOW
CONTINUES TO GROW ALONG THE
BANKS OF THE RIO GRANDE.
>> ONE'S A 12-YEAR-OLD, ONE'S A
17-YEAR-OLD.
THEY'RE FROM HONDURAS.
THEY'RE TRYING TO GET TO THEIR
MOM IN NEW ORLEANS.
>> Reporter: MANY OF THESE
CHILDREN WILL GET SENT TO THE
DONNA FACILITY WHERE THEY COULD
WAIT DAYS, EVEN WEEKS, TO GET
PLACED IN A REAL SHELTER.
>> 39 KIDS HAVE BEEN HERE OVER
15 DAYS.
IT'S JUST FOR WHATEVER REASON,
THEY HAVE FALLEN THROUGH THE
SYSTEM OR THROUGH THE CRACKS.
>> Reporter: IN A STATEMENT TO
CBS NEWS, DHS SECRETARY
ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS SAYS THEY'RE
WORKING AROUND THE DEADLOCK
QUICKLY MOVE THESE ACCOMPANIED
MINORS OUT OF THE FACILITY AND
INTO A SHELTER.
HHS SAYS THEY'RE ALSO TRYING TO
QUICKLY MOVE AND OPEN UP NEW
SHELTERS FOR THESE ACCOMPANIED
MINORS AND FAMILIES.
BOTH AGENCIES ARE EXPECTED TO
BRIEF THE HOUSE LATER TOD